hello and welcome to this video playing
tap test tap test the French exchange
they all make this move Queen d7 and
then they're in trouble
it's nothing terrible for black but it's
not very nice to play this position
white is just quicker on the e-file
okay he was worried about Knight to g5
him I seen how to play this wants to
castle problem
hmm
mmm yeah I know I took a long time there
but I had an idea this one so let's do
it
95 was the only way to make use of h6 in
some kind of way
and this is not some it's not like I'm
winning or anything but it tries to
address this h6 move in some way I'm
threatening Bishop g6 now winning a pawn
even though in this whole process I
would have no development like Bishop
takes King takes rook d7 you piayed know
he will play will create probably anyway
so maybe g v g5 is also making some
sense and now we should probably think
about Bishop d8 it's not necessary it's
not a necessary move okay it should be
form just c3
I'm not sure about the right move order
also this is possible
and it's ending I have the slightly
better pawn structure and the pair of
bishops with good technical play you can
probably try to do do for something here
I'm ship I have to go to e3 yeah that's
not really nice to keep it
I just recognized that I can also try to
play I can try to play with the night h4
yeah he didn't really didn't really do
much about it
night age 4
tonight a choice got Knight f4 against
that just I'd have four takes we should
be too and at the end it's just nothing
okay so to prevent it
I also have seafoam that's it's it's
it's interesting actually
if you imagine c4 takes bishop takes
King f8 night h4 and then he cannot
cover cg6
that even would threaten mate mmm no
it's it's an idea and he still has to
think about night age for him not super
easy to play
g5 maybe h4 simply okay he goes back so
against night h4 is going to play Knight
f8
I guess
okay prevent prevent night II for
business then try to improve see for is
something that I probably still need to
make any headway
yeah it's just not so easy he's quite
passive them
so c5 or don't I don't know really
okay
it's still very difficult for black to
make any active moves you're just
sitting there b5 I would like to get
rewarded to e5 the night
mmm yeah that is actually true yeah 95 I
don't get anywhere
Jim
remember us I don't believe that ha
unbelievable
I mean Black was completely outplayed
and then I'll play myself
ah okay f4 was bad like that was really
bad I mean yeah I have basically can
still play and grind this on forever and
ever and ever
probably I should do something
differently here so a4 is basically
winning here yeah I mean he cannot he
can barely move a piece so I must be a
lot better here I for such a strong move
like this it's not like it's something I
can't find you know but I had to hit the
clock down I don't know yeah yeah this
is just strong yeah and this is and
always painful because you if there's
one sided
this whole one-sided game and yeah 95 it
took me a long time to get to this but
the idea is that I have this Knight g6
in particular after he has castles this
is a strong idea and even he is quite
strong simply because of the
one-sidedness of the position just like
it's just torture - the whole time yeah
III ing for pushing him back oh that's
true that's true
because that doesn't work of course why
does it not look ah I can just take here
of course I didn't see it and this is
fantastic yeah okay when I was still
pushing the whole time
yeah a for a for such it's just very
strong
this is falling apart and this is also
falling apart even just taking is good
because I'm I'm getting at the getting
to the c6 weakness this is what I wanted
to do as well by rebooting the Knight g5
but he's just too quick him and this is
not a good move probably him I'm
starting to struggle a little bit
I should probably play Bishop f2 now and
simply get get to get this trade in and
the way it wins and now it's already a
bit problematic here
I'm blundering f4 I cannot do that and
he's really having the better position
now I could have taken on f4 yeah
maybe both had enough time but still
yeah I should uh yeah I've been should
have to actually and I even have Bishop
d2 because he cannot take and this is
the draw I have this is the immediate
draw yeah no no no time and this is
losing I think even the end is losing
but he was probably too unnerved with
the time it's actually draw now it's
amazing that's a draw
alright that was not good I should
really win this game with all that
pressure than I had and so on I mean I
should lose it after my blunders but
it's just like so it's such a one-sided
affair and a4 is an extremely logical
move then you have to open it up yeah
not good not well played
okay guys thanks for watching